why is it ending uh I don't know it's
Dave and Dan when they come through we
could have gone to eleven twelve
thirteen seasons but they I guess they
wanted a life you wanted it to keep
going well it you know if you've read
that my novels you know there was enough
material for more Susan so they made
certain cuts what but that's fine we
have five other shows five prequels and
development that are based on other
periods in the history of Westeros some
of them just a hundred years before Game
of Thrones some of them 5,000 years
before Game of Thrones and I'm working
on other projects Nettie and I are
working on a book together this is Nydia
Cora for she wrote an amazing book
called who fears death that HBO has
options so I'm an executive producer on
that and we're developing that to be I
hope then one of the next big is real
fantasy series now did you know Game of
Thrones would be ending with this season
or did they call you and tell you hey
let's have a chat
David and then have been saying for yeah
like five years that seven seasons was
all they would go and we got them to go
to eight but not any more than that so
yeah I had it custom a custom that there
was a period like five years ago where
they were saying seven seasons and I was
saying ten seasons and you know they won
they're the ones actually working on it
so our character that you would love to
see a spin-off with no I'm committed to
these prequels I mean I think this story
ends when it ends and I know all the
actors as great as they are all the
actors are anxious to get on and play
other roles they don't want to spend
their entire lives playing one role and
that's fine I mean there it's great
there we had such an amazing cast I mean
not only two people here tonight but
some of the people couldn't make it like
Maisie Williams sophie Turner
sibel Kate Kelly you know mark addy who
played Robert and the first thing great
great great cast I was honored to work
with them